Great planning.
How was I supposed to know?
I can't see into the future.
I'm not a witch.
No?
Then why did you dress like one?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Come on.
What did you expect?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CRACK]
[GRUNTS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You can bring your urgent
matter to me — your king.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, let's do "Get Help."
What?
- "Get Help."
- No.
- Come on, you love it.
- I hate it.
It's great.
It works every time.
- It's humiliating.
- Do you have a better plan?
No.
We're doing it.
We are not doing "Get Help."
Get help!
Please, my brother's dying!
Help him!
[THUD]
[CLATTERING]
Ah, classic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Loki, I've studied
almost every moment
of your entire life.
You've literally stabbed people
in the back, like, 50 times.
I'll never do it again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLICK]